I think there's another Oiler that's pretty
excited in fact he wanted to like make sure
that the weather's going to be good for it yeah I
think he's actually been practicing this weather
forecast and praying to those weather gods and
somehow he made it into our studio so not sure who
allowed it but avander Kane hello giving us the
weather forecast hello take it away well uh today
we have uh a minus four reading um this after
afternoon it feels like it's - 8 uh unfortunately
uh that's how it felt when I left the left to
take my daughter to school this morning um and
then what we do is we have the Heritage Classic
and what we're going to do is look at that day
in the morning it's going to be minus two the
afternoon it's going to be zero which is something
we're looking forward to and then probably right
around puck drop time it's going to be minus 3
so I think I'm probably going to be starting that
game and I'm looking forward to that so uh Woody
if you're listening that would be great um yeah
so it be minus three so I'd probably suggest to
bundle up make sure the kids are warm um throw on
a toque or a Scully if you're an American coming
up I know we have some Americans coming up I got
some family from the US coming up uh so that'll
be fun and uh looking forward to the game on uh on
Sunday awesome and we were chatting maybe getting
one of those full snowsuits yeah are you going
to get the Retro yes I'm I'm looking if you have
one and maybe let me know I can buy it off you
I don't have one oh you don't okay well maybe
our view I Jersey though oh yes great I will wear
that um the radar though it's right behind us and
right beside us so this gives us an idea about
the snow where we fall you're kind of standing
right in the middle of it so there we go this is
perfect sorry is is this good enough no that's
that's great um this gives us a better idea so
the snow is expected to stick around for the next
20 24 hours but then Evander the good news is is
it's going to make its way out so these are some
temperatures around the province today so yeah
Grand Prairie looks nice yeah what what are they
currently sitting at uh they're currently sitting
at plus one and some sun which looks fantastic
I know might have to head up there and after
is you might have to rip on up there and then
tonight things are cooling down a little bit like
bamp for instance minus 14 so a little bit chilly
it certainly is but Edmonton minus 7 and then
tomorrow things are looking great but we don't
really care about tomorrow right we're talking
about Halloween and that's really the next couple
of days here so I'll let you finish that off yeah
in Halloween it's going to be nice because I have
three young children and I'm I'd suggest you guys
get your kids out in the afternoon because it's
going to be plus seven yeah so uh that'll be a
great opportunity for your kids to get out maybe
a little earlier than they normally would and um
they that way they don't have to put their coats
over their costumes so I know yes cuz later on
it gets uh gets a little chillier um but it's
still going to feel likeus 6 so I suggest you stay
warm yeah exactly if you're going to be a little
unicorn or whatever you can put your jacket on
you're probably going to be a unicorn right uh
I was actually going to be a bottle oh oh a bottle
yeah I'm I'm going to join my daughter that's what
she wants to be so okay what are you going to
be um I be and be honest well I'm have you seen
that Haley Bieber and Justin costume where he's
in the sweatsuit behind and then Haley's in the
red dress yes I have actually that's that that's
what I so who's Justin Bieber then my boyfriend
oh yes he's going to be Justin Bieber and I am
going to be Haley but now let's cruise on over
here but we have an even better costume for the
morning news with her in daintry that will not
be Justin Bieber and Haley it's going to be
better we're going to throw it back to like
an 80s movie can we find out what it is or no no
no it's a secret secret yeah people have to watch
on Tuesday so you said your one daughter is going
to be a bottle well she has like three different
costumes right so she has like you know her school
costume her trick-or-treating costume and then she
has another Halloween party that she's going to so
one of those costumes she wants to be a bottle but
you have uh just the what about the other two
cuz there other two uh we're actually going to
go as the dalmati so um yeah my two boys will be
puppies and I think I'm going to be a puppy and
I don't know who's Cruella Deville yet but uh
we're still sorting that out maybe you'll end
up being Cruella I don't know yes you should be
so uh one last thing though going into Heritage
Classic how are you feeling as a team last night
of course was hard but yeah obviously uh not the
start we wanted to get off to but um I think this
is a great opportunity for uh our team the city
to be excited about Sunday um obviously with
uh anytime you play an outdoor game it's very
special and um it's a great opportunity for us to
kind of rally around uh having a special game and
early on in the year and an important one for us
with two points on the line so um I think we'll
have a lot of great energy and looking forward to
the game and for your first win at home no better
than not only a Heritage Classic but it for to
be against Cal that's what we were saving it
for I I know it's been tough but we were just we
wanted out that first one at home outside against
Calgary it's it's perfect and you can't give us
any inside dish on McDavid uh absolutely not I
had to ask the viewers would have been upset
if I didn't ask well good job today I think
I could be out of job if you really wanted to
continue to do the weather you did a great job
thank you I appreciate NHL career yeah well who
knows I mean you want to switch sure if you want
to play on Sunday let us know us she's ready
to go in her uh in her knee high in my boots